We can take this a bit farther.
Right now the location preference allows
us to enter a string of arbitrary size.
We'd like to make it so
that the preference is at least three
characters before accepting input.
The default preference
doesn't allow us to do that.
We're going to create
a custom preference view.
A custom preference view is similar
in construction to any other
custom view in Android.
So, consider this an introduction
to creating custom views.
A custom preference view can both
change the way the preference
is presented in the list, what happens
when it is clicked, and in this case,
the way the alert dialog behaves that is
used to back the edit text preference.
We're going to give our custom
view a custom attribute for
the minimum length of the location.
Mostly because custom
attributes are cool.
So let's start there.
We'll create a new values
file called attrs.xml.
We build custom attributes using
the declare-styleable tag.
Each attribute in declare-styleable
has a name and a format.
The next thing to do is to create our
custom edit text preference by creating
a new class that extends
edit text preference.
And that new class will create
a constructor that uses a context and
an attribute set.
That attribute set is what we use to
read the value of our custom attribute.
We call
context.gettheme.obtainStyledAttributes
passing in this value.